the no side has won the referendum with  an overwhelming majority and we have to  respect the vote of the Greek people the  difficult day it is a broad majority in  Greece and the promise of Prime Minister  tsipras to the Greek people that with  the know the position of Greece for  negotiating a better deal would become  better as in my eyes not true it's now  up to the Greek government to make  proposals which could convince the 18  other member states of the eurozone and  the institutions in Brussels that it is  necessary possible and even effective to  renegotiate a humanitarian program is  needed immediately and I hope that the  Greek government will make in the next  coming hours meaningful and constructive  proposals allowing that it is meaningful  and possible to renegotiate if not we  are entering in a very difficult even  dramatic time